thank you very much Rachel and welcome
to my talk JavaScript engines the good
parts initially I was going to give this
talk together with Bryant Olsen from
Microsoft
you know nice guy blonde hair working on
a JavaScript VM but yeah then life
happened and now I'm standing you alone
what are you talking about I'm right
here man
[Applause]
this is weird
yeah now we have to Brian look-alikes I
think I cannot do a talk with both of
you sorry okay so thank you Peter for
the cameo yeah Walter Peter alright so
with that out of the way let's get
started with the actual presentation
JavaScript engines the good parts
nowadays JavaScript runs not only in web
browsers but also in ODS in react native
in electron it even runs on IOT devices
and I've recently been told it even runs
in space so there's that javascript is
everywhere nowadays as a developer
learning JavaScript or improving your
JavaScript skills is an excellent time
investment
so let's take a look today behind the
scenes of how javascript engines work
this is v8 it's the JavaScript engine
used in Google Chrome node.js and
electron for example and recently we've
been speaking and thinking a lot about
how v8 works behind the scenes however
it's not just v8 out there there are
more JavaScript engines out there so
we're gonna do a little bit different
today yeah actually we're going to look
at some of the fundamentals that are
common to all the JavaScript engines out
there and these fundamentals make it
possible to write these amazing
JavaScript applications that we see
today and of which we held a lot of this
conference already so starting with that
it's not just v8 there's also an engine
called SpiderMonkey which is the
JavaScript engine that powers Firefox
and fun fact there's even a note fork
using SpiderMonkey which is called
spider note I really like that name
spider notes then there's microsoft's
javascript engine which they use in edge
it's called chakra and the main part of
the chakra engine is open source as
chakracore there is a note chakra core
project which is basically an odious
flavor powered by chakracore instead of
v8 and that's not all as also JSC or
javascript core which is the engine that
was was writ initially built for WebKit
and it's nowadays powering Safari but
also react native
so these are the major JavaScript
engines out there and if you want to
play around with any of these engines
directly which is without going through
and and better like a browser or no TS
then you can install its tool called JSP
you so you install it using NPM you
install it globally you follow the
readme instructions and after that you
can basically just run v8 SpiderMonkey
chakra GSC straight from the command
line and the JavaScript you run in there
will run directly in the engine itself
ok so now that you have all these
JavaScript engines installed on your
system let's take a look what they all
have in common it all starts with the
JavaScript code that you write so the
JavaScript engine parses the source and
turns it into an abstract syntax tree or
ast and this ast gets fed into the
interpreter which can then start to do
its thing which is to produce bytecode
and this is pretty cool because at this
point the engine is running your
JavaScript code however to make it run
more smoothly and more efficiently
there's also an optimizing compiler
pipeline so the bytecode gets fed into
the optimizing compiler alongside
profiling data that we collect while the
code is running and that way the
optimising compiler can make some
assumptions based on the profiling data
and generate highly optimized machine
code that runs more efficiently and if
one of those assumptions turns out to be
incorrect later it's no big deal because
we can just deoptimization the
interpreter so let's focus on the
important part here which is the part
where the code actually gets run so each
JavaScript engine has some kind of
pipeline with an interpreter and an
optimizing compiler pipeline the
interpreter generates bytecode and the
optimizing compiler generates highly
optimized machine code wait you just
stole my punchline
this was the v8 slide so actually that's
exactly our v8 works our interpreter is
named ignition and the internet filter
is responsible for generating and
executing the byte code and as its as
it's executing the byte code it collects
profiling data and when a function gets
hot so let's say you call it a couple of
times then we feed it to turbofan which
is our optimizing compiler and that uses
this profiling data to generate highly
optimized
I love hot functions SpiderMonkey does
it a little bit differently they have
not one but two optimizing compilers so
the interpreter optimizes into the
baseline compiler which produces
somewhat optimized code and combines
with profiling data that it gathers
while that somewhat optimized code is
running it gets fat into the Iron Monkey
optimizing compiler which produces more
highly optimized machine code and you
did it again
so this is exactly chakracore except
that they have different names so in
chakra core the first optimizing
compiler is not named baseline but
simple JIT where it sends for
just-in-time compiler and it generates
somewhat optimized code however when a
function gets really hot then it feeds
it to fold it and that generates really
awesome code out of this
and then there's JSC which takes it to
the extreme with not one not two three
optimizing compilers so it all starts
with ll in the low-level interpreter
which produces the bytecode and from
there they can optimize into the
baseline compiler which produces
somewhat optimized code but from this
baseline compiler based on some
heuristics they can either optimize into
the DFG compiler or the FTL compiler so
based let's look at all what else
all these JavaScript engines have in
common by zooming in on some aspects and
how they implement them in common
because besides these differences that
we just discussed at a very high level
all engines follow the same architecture
they have some kind of parser and then
an interpreter and compiler pipeline for
example how do JavaScript engines
implement the JavaScript object model
and which tricks to the use to speed up
accessing properties on objects as it
turns out all major engines implement
this more or less similarly wait but
Matias isn't it the case that all
objects in JavaScript are just
dictionaries right that's true if you
look at the JavaScript back it turns out
that objects are actually dictionaries
with string keys and the string keys
mapped to not just the value but to
something that the spec calls property
attributes so in this example the X and
the y are string keys in a dictionary
just according to the spec and the five
and six values are just values within
the property attributes for dot property
so other than the value
property attributes can also store
whether the property is writable
enumerable and configurable and this is
not something that JavaScript engines
make up it's part of the ACMA script
spec writable determines whether the
property can be reassigned to enumerable
means that the property can show up in
foreign loops and configurable means
that it's a deletable property and you
can actually get to these property
attributes in JavaScript for any object
and any property by using the object get
own property descriptor API interesting
so that's how JavaScript sees objects
but what if we take a race well you can
think of a race as a special case of
objects really there's only a couple of
differences one difference is that
arrays have special handling for array
indices with what scenario makes an
array index is a spec term basically
arrays are limited to two to the power
of 32 minus one items so that's the
maximum array length you can have so
when array index is just any valid
integer within that range from 0 to 2 to
the power of 32 minus 2 okay so not
every integer is a valid error in X
exactly okay
so you mentioned more differences oh
yeah another difference is the magical
length property that arrays have wait
wait wait metrics it is pure magic like
if you look at this example the array
has a length of 2 in the beginning then
we add another item to the array and
automatically the length property is
updated the JavaScript spec defines how
it is and JavaScript engines have to do
this automatically in the background as
a JavaScript developer you don't have to
go and manually update it so let's take
a look at how JavaScript defines a race
they're stored similarly to objects for
example all the keys including the array
indexes or represented as strings
explicitly so the first element in your
array will be the string key 0 and the
length property is just another property
that happens to be non enumerable and
non configurable once an element is
added to the array javascript
automatically updates the value property
attributes for this property for the
length property ok that looks really
similar to the objects in the ETA so now
we know how objects are defined and
JavaScript and what observation is
many programs mostly operate on objects
and the most common operation in these
programs is actually the property access
so it's like a common thing to do I
guess if I make that forest right and in
fact what we see in the wild is that
most objects in the same program tend to
have the same property keys at least
there is a set of objects that have the
same so you could say that all of them
have the same shape right that makes
sense it's also very common to access
the same property on different objects
that have the same shape so with that in
mind javascript engines can optimize
object property access based on these
shapes so let's take a look at how that
works okay let's assume we have this one
object here which has properties x and y
and it's represented using this
dictionary data structure that we saw
before so the x and y are stored as
strings in the dictionary and point to
the property attributes for these
individual properties so if you then
write something like object dot Y in
your program the engine has to reach out
to the JS object find the key inside of
it reach out to the property attributes
and eventually load the value from it
okay so where are these property
attributes stored
do we store them as part of the GS
object data structure itself because
that seems a little wasteful based on
what you just said if we expect more
properties well more objects to have the
same shape then you would end up
duplicating all that information for
every single objects that seems wasteful
memory wise that's a good observation
and I think some people made this
observation already at least this is
kind of how we represent it in
JavaScript engines nowadays so what we
do is that the engine stores the shape
separately from the values of the
attributes so like in this case the
shape describes which properties you
have and which property attributes you
have on this except for the value so
instead the property information
contains the offset where you find the
value inside of the JS object the offset
where you find the value and it totally
makes sense when you start to look at
multiple objects that have the same
shape so now you only need
one instance of this shape and the
object only contained the information
that is unique to this object so you
don't repeat this information that is
common anyways so even if we have a
million objects there will only be one
shape as they all have the same shape
and they will all point to the same one
that's true it seems like it would save
a lot of memory and this is not even
something that JavaScript engines made
up this has been there before so like
there's been a lot of research on this
and if you look at academic papers then
they of not called shapes but hidden
classes that would be a confusing name
in a javascript engine because classes
are already a thing in JavaScript what
you find that confusing you know that v8
calls them Maps it's the same problem
it's a terrible name
okay how about types for chakracore
that's not confusing at all okay I can
offer a structure for JSC I like the
name structure that kind of makes sense
but I'm gonna keep calling them shapes
because that's what SpiderMonkey calls
them and I like the name so Benedict it
seems like it's a common thing too if
you have an object to then add a
property to it so what if you have an
object with a certain shape you add a
property to it how does the JavaScript
engine find the new shape so what
JavaScript engines do is that the shapes
inside of the engine form so called
transition chains so let me run you
through this example quickly let's
assume we start with the empty object so
this object initially points to the
empty shape that doesn't have any
property on us okay so now you start
adding a property to it like in our case
we add X which means we transition to a
new shape that has the property X on it
with the property information and we
append the value for this property to
the object and then we record inside of
the shape inside of the property
information that this value can be found
at offset zero now so let's say we add
yet another property to it like in this
case Y then we do the same as before we
introduce a new shape that contains this
new property in addition to the X
property and we append the value to the
object and we record that the value can
now be found at offset 1 however if we
do this then we might waste a lot of
space
we repeat the full table all the time
plus the new thing that is added right
we're repeating acts like all the
information for X is duplicated all the
information facts is duplicated so
that's not really what engines do
instead what you do is you just remember
the information about the new property
that was added Ryan we don't have to
repeat information for X because we can
just find it earlier in the chain that's
exactly the trick so we introduce a back
link to the previous shape so that you
can just walk the transition chain
backwards until you find the shape that
introduces the property and then you
know where to look into the object so
just looking at this example if you now
need to find X on it you would start at
the last shape and it's C okay this is
not the one I'm looking for because it
introduces Y then you walk back once and
oh god this X awesome no I know where to
find it so that's what happens when you
type o dot X in JavaScript now I know so
what if you have two objects with the
same shape then you add a different
property to each of them that way you
cannot really change these shapes rights
there's no way to change no but what we
do instead is we introduce so called
transition trees and we branch off in
various ways from shapes so let's look
at this example this is what we learnt
before already so we have the empty
object we introduced X on it which means
we introduced two shapes and a single
chain from the empty shape to the shape
of contains X now if we run the second
line of code if we start again with an
empty object and we add a property Y to
it then we branch off the empty shape
with a property Y and we end up with a
tree that contains a total of three
shapes in two chains right so does that
mean if we walk up the shape tree we
always end up at the empty shape no not
necessarily
there's always an exception to the rule
and the reason is that JavaScript
engines have special treatment for
object literals that already introduce
properties from the get-go so like in
this case the first thing is what we saw
before we start with the empty object
and then we add X to it
and the second line is we start with an
object that already contains X and you
can imagine that it might be a bit
faster to just construct objects with
the properties on it already so what we
end up with for example in v8 and in
SpiderMonkey is this is the first case
that we know so here we start from the
empty object and we add X to it later
which is exactly what we had before but
now the second example we start with an
object that already contains X from the
beginning so we introduce a new root
shape that already contains this X and
we don't branch it off the empty shape
right and so we can just skip over that
empty shape altogether in this case
that's true nice and the reason why we
do this is to keep the transition change
short because otherwise it's a lot of
metadata that we waste and also because
it's more efficient to construct objects
this way it sounds super familiar didn't
you write a blog post about exactly this
shameless plug yes I did
so I actually published a blog post last
year about this where I try to highlight
how these subtleties with the shapes can
have effects on real-world performance
especially for common pet enfant and
react applications I read that blog post
and it talks a lot about this thing
called I sees what are those that's
actually the magic inside of the engine
no it's not more magic it's mo metric so
I see stands for inline cash and the
inline caches are the key ingredients
that is necessary to make JavaScript run
fast and it's also the main motivation
for actually having shapes so how do
these a ICS work exactly so JavaScript
engines use ICS to memorize information
where to find properties on objects so
that we don't need to repeat expensive
property look-up on each property access
okay so how does that work okay let me
run you through this example so we have
a function get X which takes an object
oh and lots the property X from it that
seems like a common thing to do like get
a property somewhere your I think I've
seen it in the world so if we feed this
to JavaScript core then it generates the
following bytecode so this bytecode
contains two
structions the get BIID instruction
which does the property lookup in this
case it's get by ID loads x from arc 1
first argument which is au and source
the result into log 0 and the next
instruction just returns whatever is in
lock 0 okay this makes sense but how do
I see is come into play here so it's not
just that JSC also introduces an inline
cache into the byte code so in this case
into the get by ID instruction this IC
contains two uninitialized slots
initially and when we now call this
function let's say we call it with an
object x : a as we learned before this
has a shape that contains X and let's
say in this case the property value for
x is found at offset zero now we invoke
the function with this what do we need
to do we need to reach out to the shape
of this object search for X inside load
the property information from it
determine the offset then go back to the
object and load whatever is that offset
zero that sounds like a lot of work it
is and since the engine already did this
work it makes a lot of sense to memorize
the information that we can reuse on the
next call for this function so let's say
we call it sorry it makes a lot of sense
to record this information for the next
call so what we do is we memorize the
shape that we have seen and also the
offset at which we found X inside of
this shape so when we then call this
function again with an object that has
the same shape we only need to check oh
it's the same shape oh okay no it's
already offset zero so I don't need to
reach out to the property information at
all wow we can just get rid of that an
expensive look up altogether that sounds
great
yes and it's significantly faster so how
it is work for arrays where you can
expect most elements to be array indices
most properties so you wouldn't want to
store property attributes for each and
every array index in each and every
array in your code base that seems
wasteful because you know that they're
gonna be writable
enumerable configurable definitely that
we total wastes of space and metadata
would explode so what happens instead so
all engines actually make use of the
fact that all array in the
properties are writable configurable
enumerable data properties so let's look
at this array as we know an array has a
property length which is this magical
property and let's say the length is
stored at offset 1 inside of the array
for all the elements that are actually
in the array that are indexed by error
in it says we store them in a separate
element backing store and this packing
store only stores the values and it has
this implicit tech attached to it which
says that whatever you find in here is
writable innumerable and configurable so
we don't have to store any property
attributes for array elements no because
they all match the default they are all
default values anyways but what if
someone overrides one of those
attributes though this is JavaScript
Java Script is pretty wild I know you
want but you can totally do this though
like what if I use object or defined
property or on an array elements and I
set one of its attributes do the non
default value of false
you know Matias whenever you do
something like this you kill a kitten so
like just look at this one oh you cannot
kill it impossible or you want to kill
this one it would be rude or come on my
heart melts yeah there's the family of
kittens remember don't do this okay but
kittens aside so for these edge cases
the engine represents the entire backing
store for the elements as a dictionary
which map from array indices to
full-fledged property attributes so very
much like in the JavaScript
specification so even if I just use this
object of defined property on one array
index then the whole array gets stored
like this yes
oh yeah basic assumption of the engine
is that you don't do this also remember
the kittens come on got it yeah I think
you're saying that I should avoid using
object I'll define property and array
indexes which is a weird thing to do
anyway yes yeah okay I guess I won't do
that again so we've learned a lot about
JavaScript engine internals today and we
got some actual coding advice out of it
as well so let's recap the main
takeaways always initialize your object
in exactly the same way
so that they don't end up having
different shapes and second don't mess
with property attributes of array
elements so that they can distort and
operate it on efficiently think of the
kittens and that's it thanks for
listening
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]